[Music]
it's in all of us
that fear
of being hurt
because we're queer
back to New York for being so fabulous
I remember the first gay bar I walked
into I thought oh my god I've been
missing this my entire life it just felt
like home queer Bars were one of the few
places where we could come and feel safe
and then all of a sudden
[Music]
everything was taken away
my dad went down to New York on a
business trip and
never came home
my brother my uncle my friend he just
disappeared these were pickup crimes
they were last seen at a gay bar Five
Oaks the townhouse clearly a Serial
murderer going after gay men was on the
loose it was so frightening because
everyone was a suspect the queer
Community was very much trying to push
law enforcement to give a at this
time we wouldn't put it past the police
to kill us
hate crimes against gays and lesbians
are up all over the country makes people
feel like maybe they're not safe and
maybe a murderer isn't going to get
caught we were scared this guy is going
to strike again then could I be next
Peter Anderson Thomas Mulkey Anthony
they weren't just a statistic they had
their own story too
this guy was a sort of talk for years so
you're gonna make a mistake
I like that
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]